Ron Rivera joining us here on the show
how are you coach I'm doing great risk
are you what meetings does a head coach
the National Football League have on the
last Monday of June coach well just
stuff going through you look at some
some paperwork stuff that we have start
getting ready to try and cap you know I
can make sure I get everything done then
once I leave on vacation not worry about
anything like it when I get back into
town okay Wendy's vacation next week
like most of the cargo that's coming up
it's coming up real soon so I'm excited
about that where you go can i with you
on my knee prime Oh what is it go back
to the west coast you know visit visit
family out there now looking forward to
it be nice little break okay so then you
tap out but do you look at film at all I
mean how much can you as an NFL head
coach unplugged coach oh I'll believe my
mom's like I will leave everything at
home I'm bringing iPads or Microsoft
carbon I'm believing everything at the
office and we're going to go out and not
enjoy our family for a good week what's
the last movie you saw oh you know what
my wife and daughter took me to see
Wonder Woman oh okay what do you think I
liked it was fun I was entertaining yes
I'd say she does the young lady places a
very athletic young lady and it was the
next thing I was next to me do you think
she runs a faster 40 than I do coaches
Oh as you're saying saying gal gadot run
right I'd say she just might mm-hmm I
bet how's your quarterback doing feel
good you know I'm you know from from all
indications he's right on track you know
I like with whatever team was he doing
with them and you know I'm looking
forward to seeing them in a couple of
weeks well I saw a hype video just
shortly before you joined us on the show
today that the team made a video with
music and him throwing in the locker
room his first his first throw since
shoulder surgery we're in a new era
coach so so he's throwing just lightly
off field or is he where is he in his
rehab cam it's my understanding it's
right on tracks right where the trainer
wants him and in fact up during that
little session I was told you know the
trainer had to calm him down if he said
he started to put some pepper on is it
out a little too soon let's let's lower
back down so mine saying that was going
very well
now so when your training camp opens up
your you think he'll be full go what do
you say I believe so I mean again I
don't want to be ahead of the trainers I
know they're going through the whole
process of this rehab program and you
know hopefully we'll have a good sense
for once we get there you're closer
training cap okay and Christian
McCaffrey you're your first your top
draft pick this year you finally got a
chance to take a look at him in the
mandatory minicamp based the reason why
he wasn't there is a rule in the NFL
that does not allow a prospect to join
the team until the academic year of the
school that he just left is finished and
Stanford didn't finish until June what
do you think of that rule well you know
I think you know the rules of our game
you know the rules put in place through
G for a reason you know but with with
with the way the players are now today
in terms of looking toward either level
guys don't you know they're not
enrolling in in the next semester the
next quarter so in spite Joyce you
because you don't know where they're
gonna end up playing so a lot of them
seem to be doing that and you know all
they're really doing at that time is
they're just working out getting
themselves ready and you know I think it
needs to be really making it good yeah I
don't make that decision but I just I
just think it might be time to revisit
the role what is the rule in place for
best you can tell what I think it was so
that you know we don't put pressure on
the players to come out early you know
we encouraging the stay in school
encourage them to do things that they
need to do in terms of you know of their
graduation and you know so it's really
you know it's just one of those things I
think to protect the player what about
now maybe instituting a rule that if the
kid sits out as a bowl game because he
wants to stay healthy for the draft he's
already indicated it's time to start
working out as a professional yeah but
then you know mobile presentations will
stop playing and that's one thing that
we don't want to do we don't want to
take it you know hey I don't want to put
a player in position one he's got to
make a choice like that that that'd be
unfair to the universities Ron Rivera
Panthers head coach joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show where did you stand
on that subject while interviewing
Christian at the combine and whenever
you did throughout the talent evaluation
portion because that was such
a big conversation that McCaffrey sat
out his Sun Bowl game against North
Carolina and I know some guys that I
work with Marshall Faulk other Hall of
Famers had issues that that that
McCaffrey sat out where did you stand on
the subject well quite a young man made
his own decision and that's really the
way we looked at it he made a decision
that was you know geared towards his
future more so than anything else and so
you know at the end of the day it's
something that he decides some people
have opinions and they're going to live
with their decisions but he was very
upfront he's very frank about it and he
was very honest and you know it's just
one of those things that that was his
decision so you don't view this as
potentially a window should he have say
a walk year and as a professional that
he might take a different approach while
being on your team no I don't believe so
I believe this is a different set of
circumstances this is a young man
looking towards towards the future and
it played out it played out in the last
two years where you saw some terrific
football players that were basic getting
radiances both interest how is Michael
Oher it's so rare to hear about an
offensive lineman still being in a
concussion protocol in the middle of the
summer code I'm like don't know the
biggest thing writers knows that he's in
the protocol right now and going through
the process and you know all indications
right now is he's going to continue in
it and we'll go from that I was Lou
Kuechly doing folks feeling great Luke's
had a great off season good good with
the occasion minicamp and you know we're
excited to get back on the football
field come our training camp how
concerned were you and you saw what we
all saw on that Thursday night when I
was very concerned yell but again you
know just looking you know looking at
that one weekly tree try to do in terms
of you know they they approach if
they're getting a meal back on onto the
football field and doing things you know
the way the doctors prescribed yeah we
we we follow the protocol the way it was
intended and as a result you know I made
a tough decision at the end of year not
to call you if I could give you the
proverbial magic wand
coach Ron Rivera to change a rule in the
National Football League what would it
be um in all honesty I don't double I
think but one would be happy to answer
the the protocol questions you know I
think that I really do I think that's a
tough situation I think there's a lot of
pressure on a lot of people you know
players coaches and doctors meaning what
like me wanting to find out from you if
ski cleese coming out or Wars coming out
that that shouldn't be asked of a head
coach yeah I really do I think that's
you know the over thinker you know we
got to be careful because I um you know
I don't think we should seem we should
be answering those Christmas well I
don't know I mean we as players don't
honor as coaches you know no I think
sometimes we make a little bit of undue
pressure on fire so about having to to
get healthy fast I mean the truth of
matter is the only one who really knows
his the flavor I mean he's only really
owns who knows how he truly feels you
know I think if we live it to the
players and the doctors you know we'll
we'll get guys back when when they're
ready to play and if I could allow you
to have one item in the NFL that is
currently not reviewable by replay that
you as a head coach said let's let's put
that in there let's review it what would
that be oh well you know I mean there's
so many people have talked about having
every play ability to challenge every
fight you know sometimes you want that
sometimes you don't and and I just you
know I just think we're in a very touchy
situation because it you know the
referees return do the best I can I mean
they're trying to judge the game at real
time and and and we've just got it you
know we I think we as coaches you know
we've gotta learn to be patient with
them and just appreciate their tough
situation and then there's the the
relaxation if you will of the
celebration rules that your quarterback
your quarterback still found a monster
loophole in with his dad of a couple of
years ago I'm wondering what you think
of that you know I I think that's one
thing that we regulate it a little too
much I'm kind of glad they brought it
back you know I do think there's a
certain point where you got to be very
careful you got to be willing to keep
the good taste in you know involved in
the game I think that's still that's
probably the biggest thing that we've
just got to beware because there's a lot
of young people that are watching the
game too now well in a couple of minutes
I have left with you here
there is however going to be a clock a
play clock the moment that a touchdown
is signified this year you know where
I'm going with this and that if there is
no replay on the score at the 20-second
mark of that play clock you are going to
have to get your place kicker out there
to kick in extra point and if let's just
say one particular player is dancing a
couple of seconds longer or let's say is
dabbing in the manner that your
quarterback has let's just go out there
and just put it out there have you
spoken to Cam Newton about keeping an
eye on a play clock or anybody else on
your team know that that will come once
we get into training can we rule
one of these are common here we get
those set of rules from the referees yep
you know the video we go through and
we'll do that when we get to we're
pretty appropriate ah well will number
one have a specific conversation with
you no I think in general the whole
group will okay and then lastly I know
you got a meeting to get to
we saw Ryan Khalil have a fun video at
cams expense that we were told by Ryan
was received its inaugural screening in
one of your powerpoints is that the
truth coach yes it did it did you know
we had a little bit of fun about it
you don't again it all goes back to the
whole thing that you know be careful
what you put you put on social media you
know you got to make sure you're putting
your the right types of things out there
and you know it was it was kind of fun
we had a good fun way a lot of fun with
well but you also have to know that cam
would have a sense of humor right before
you care but I know you do I know he's
preciate that's for sure
okay coach thanks for the time enjoy
your vacation when you get it okay all
right appreciate you got us Ron Rivera I
have to said coach joining us here in
the Rochester so Rich Eisen shows
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy